the invasion of Gaza getting delayed as
Iran ramps up direct threats against
America Israeli troops and tanks briefly
raiding Northern Gaza overnight as they
prepare the battlefield before an
expected full-blown ground Invasion
those developments come as Iran plays
with fire the Pentagon revealing Iran
backed proxies attacking US troops in
Iraq and Syria 16 times since October 7
17 and the radical regime feels bold
enough to issue this warning to the
United States while at the
UN I say frankly to the American
Statesmen who are now managing the
genocide in Palestine that we do not
welcome to expansion of the war in the
region but I warn if the genocide in Gaz
contines news they will not beared from
this
fire instead of directly dealing with
the Iranian threat the White House has
other priorities kamla Harris is
following Joe Biden's lead by lecturing
Israel on a two-state
solution we stand for the importance of
understanding that we must prioritize
humanitarian
values that the rules of War require
that there be no intent itional attack
of civilians that humanitarian Aid be
administered that we do all that we can
to ensure that there will not be an
escalation in
particular by Iran's proxies in that
region of the world and we have not
abandoned and we still are profoundly
committed to a two-state solution is
dead I won't even ask a question on her
uh Jesse the Iran the Iranian foreign
minister in the United States in New
York across town actually comes here and
warns the United States will not be
spared if the war in Gaza continues
right here in New York City and by the
way not drawing a distinction between
Israel fighting in Gaza and the United
States Dana just told me she wants to go
to the UN and make a citizen's arrest
I've never seen her this angry before I
mean the guy is like a war criminal
defund the UN while we're at it and just
throw that whole building into the East
River so Biden's being tested by the
Iranians the Iranian proxies keep taking
these pot shots at us bases now some of
the service members have now sustained
critical brain injuries and the Pentagon
was not honest about what happened we
just found out about it
eventually Joe Biden and the generals
are going to have to respond you cannot
continue to sustain these types of
injuries over and over and over again
and do nothing they only understand
strength
so and they're like gang members they're
they're going to push and push and push
and push until the police say enough and
that's what they're doing right now
they're testing us Biden's in a pickle
because of Ukraine Russia and because of
what we've done with our energy sources
here he's keeping the Iranian oil game
in Play because he needs to keep oil
prices at a certain level and this is
what I would do I would say screw the
Ukraine situation right now I'd send a
missile right into the you the energy
infrastructure of Iran they have a hub
right by the Sea where they export
everything they own I would knock it the
hell out of there and then I'd say all
right guys you're on your own for the
next three years until you rebuild and
that'll get them to shut
up what do you think of that Brian um
first off I we know exactly where those
militias are we know where they're
located we know Iraq like the back of
our hands we've hit them before we've
hit them often we know how they started
who finances them and we're only
allowing them to knock the Rockets out
of the sky the drones out of the sky if
I am the family of somebody serving
right now in Iraq 2,500 900 over in
Syria I'm outraged I'm letting my kids
become targets I signed up for this
country and you're not allowing us to
use the $900 billion we put into it the
only thing Iran understands is direct
action and what we're doing is showing
weakness the only thing in that region
is successful is showing muscle and
instead we allow this guy to come here
and threaten us if we don't we don't
knock it off and support stop supporting
Israel that we're they're going to start
bombing us we're going to feel the fire
is he insane when is the president gonna
g to go get some steel in his spine and
start hitting the militia and letting
them know it's only going to get worse
from there yeah well and you know Piers
B Biden as recently as yesterday said
don't it was I think like his ninth
don't uh and they keep doing and doing
and how long does this go on before Iran
starts to believe that they shouldn't
well you're already seeing uh Iran
attacking uh Americans around the world
you're seeing Iran financing Hamas whove
just launched a massive terror attack
not just on Israelis but also Americans
I'm not sure what more they need to do
before America takes action to defend
itself and the fact that this guy can
come to New York City and speak with
that Brazen impunity in that way about
the United States and you know you look
at look let's be honest um I don't want
to be aist but you look at Joe Biden do
you really think that the Ayatollah is
afraid of him in Iran care what he is
saying about don't and then kamla Harris
One Heartbeat Away from being the
president of the United States they're
laughing right they're laughing at
America and that's not a good place for
anybody it's not a good place for us in
the UK If America is being laughed at in
this way so something has to happen
right and I I have believed from the
start of this conflict three weeks ago
that Iran is behind all of this of
course they have deliberately financed
there's a report in the Wall Street
Journal which said that hundreds of
Hamas terrorists had gone to Iran 500
have been trained in Iran before this
terror attack I think it the scale of it
was on a scale that could only have been
financed by somebody like Iran so they
have already effectively declared a
proxy war in America CU a lot of
Americans died that day right so at some
point America has to show Iran actually
you can't do this like we did we at
Salman right yeah all right Dana hit it
so yesterday we talked about how in
Beirut the leaders of Hamas Hezbollah
and Palestinian Islamic Jihad all got to
have a meeting and drink tea and have
the Press pool come in for coverage and
they're just allowed to go about doing
this but the Hezbollah media office
okay there's one thing second thing we
have to give them a visa to allow him
here and just like we did in September
and what was the day that we gave them
the Visa in September when they came
here oh it was the day that we announced
we were doing a prisoner exchange MH and
$6 billion were going to be unfrozen for
the
Iranians and three I believe of the
prisoners that were supposed to go back
to Iran we're like we'd prefer to stay
here in America and we let them so
here's what I would do I'd not let him
go home you can also block him from
leaving make him stay right here at the
hotel until all the hostages are
released one of those migrant hotels
absolutely Roos yeah make them St at the
Roos you can block him from you can you
you gave him the permission to come in
yep you can block him from you know what
make him say at piers's hotel that's
punishment and what is that hotel
Pier I'll tell you what happens at my
hotel we practice egg and Spoon
raises you practice a as you may have
seen on his on his prime time show last
night the Donald Trump scale whining
about the stolen egg and Spoon
race I want to recount hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else